hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
correlative cryo imaging for cell
biology
i'm susie valdez of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by
leica microsystems and abio to learn
more about
our sponsors please click on the sponsor
logo on the left
side of your screen so let's get started
i'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive and we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
at any time you want during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
also please notice you share this
webinar on your personal
social media just click on the social
sharing tab
and let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation simply click
on the support tab
found at the top right of your
presentation window or report your
problem
by clicking on the ask a question box
located
on the far left of your screen i now
present
today's speaker dr elizabeth wright and
also joining us
for our live question and answer session
is dr jay yang
and dr brian seibert for a complete
biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
join me now in welcoming dr wright dr
wright you may now begin
your presentation welcome
good afternoon thank you for joining us
for today's webinar on correlative
lights and electron microscopy for cell
biology
we would like to thank our sponsors and
co-organizers like microsystems and
alveo labs
we would also like to thank labruz for
hosting this webinar series
as mentioned my name is elizabeth wright
i am a professor at the university of
wisconsin-madison
our research group focuses on questions
related to infectious disease
and human cell dysfunction we also
develop and use a range of
cryo-correlative
imaging methods for our research i would
like to introduce two other presenters
for this webinar
and webinar series dr jay yang
is a cryo-em biophysicist in the group
and develops light microscopy
cryo-em and cryo-clem methods and
software tools
dr brian seibert is a structural
virologist on the team
he develops and uses light microscopy
cryo-em
and cryo-clem workflows for virology
research
to get all started here's a brief
overview of today's webinar
i will introduce cryo-em at uw-madison
highlight the major emphasis areas in
structural biology and connections to
cryo-em
and clem from there i will discuss some
of the theoretical and practical aspects
of labeling biological targets
and include research examples we will
discuss clem equipment options and
workflows
including research examples i will
present some of the future areas for
clem technology development
i will then provide a few suggestions
about resources
make some acknowledgements and point to
future events
the right lab moved to uw-madison in
2018
to begin the next phase of work in
cryo-em structural studies of host
pathogen systems
simultaneously we set out to build a
cryo-em research center at uw-madison
in the department of biochemistry to
support the research endeavors of
investigators
across the uw campus regionally
nationally and internationally we have
assembled a team of the pi
two staff scientists eric and matt four
post-doctoral research associates jay
brian julian and daniel and two graduate
students
joe and juan members of the group are
engaged in facility management
development
research projects and cryo-em education
in addition to our team we have a suite
of instrumentation to support all major
cry when workflows
from the basics of sample optimization
by negative staying
cem to see single particle data
collection
and 3d map determination
we specialize in areas associated with
cryoklem
and the cryolic and cryoelectron
tomography and have built resources to
support these studies
of biological targets from light level
imaging
through cryofib sim sample milling
cryo-et data collection 3d
reconstruction
rendering and sub volume averaging
the members of the team and the
instrumentation are essential for the
success of cryon studies in the wright
lab
and at the cmrc at uw-madison
in structural biology there are unique
disciplines that support investigations
of isolated purified
complexes through an entire through to
an envir
entire virus cell or tissue
we use techniques that allow us to study
the structure and function
of the macromolecule or complex at the
highest possible resolution
and with the highest level of contextual
information
many investigators in these fields are
developing the technologies to improve
correlation
and integration between the methods and
the resulting data
cryo-em methods hardware and
computational algorithms
have improved significantly over the
last few years to support both
atomic level resolution structure
determination of individual complexes
and slightly lower resolution structures
of intact entities
that provide enhanced contextual
information
we are focused on improving technologies
that support better correlation
between cryo-em and fluorescence
microscopy
so why do we use fluorescence microscopy
correlative lights and electron
microscopy and cryo-em
briefly cryo-em technologies were
pioneered to retain specimen hydration
and reduced electron beam radiation
damage to biological samples
while imaged in the vacuum of the
electron microscope
these advances have allowed data to be
collected that could then be
computationally processed to generate
native 3d structures
of macromolecules the pioneering efforts
and recent advances in the field
led to the 2017 nobel prize in chemistry
to be awarded to
joachim frank jacques dubuchet and
richard henderson
in kind fluorescence light microscopy
was developed for resolving targets of
interest
during the imaging of live or fixed
specimen in particular biological
specimens
numerous awards including several nobel
prizes have been presented for
developments in
fluorescence microscopy labeling and
imaging technology
finally correlative light and electron
microscopy grew from the need to define
structures
of complexes that were spatially
resolved in biological specimens
we can differentiate clem methods by
whether they produce indirect
or direct correlation information in
cryoklem
the goal is to achieve direct
correlation
data from the specimen
in our laboratory we develop and use
clem methods and workflows to support
structure function studies of a range of
biological targets
however while we are able to correlate
well between
light microscopy and electron microscopy
our goal is to further improve
technology so that there is greater
correlation to
molecular biology and physio physiology
experiments
we and others are developing tools so
that the exact sample that is imaged
also produces the essential molecular
data
this connection is critical for many
reasons
for example when we image a specimen we
resolve the structure
of the virus for example and the
macromolecules that make it
however we can only infer from related
molecular experiments
that the likelihood the likely number of
infectious virus particles
on that specimen that we've imaged if
we are able to design pipelines that
support
one-to-one correlation we could define
the structure
and function of a particular virus to
ultimately design
better therapeutics and vaccines
as we consider the cryo-em workflow to
use
so much depends on the biological
question
what is the target isolate isolated
macromolecules
a macromolecular complex or assembly
whole cells or whole cells that have
been perturbed
by a virus or other agent or whole cells
and tissue at the same time there is a
balance between
context and the achievable resolution
based on how the sample has been
processed
and imaged when we move forward with a
project
we consider the workflow in four phases
sample optimization and preparation
specimen preservation
where we can use plunge freezing or
other high pressure freezing or
self-pressurized rapid freezing
approaches
the imaging pathway that we're going to
employ for iom
imaging to collect 2d images
cryoelectron tomography imaging
to collect tilt series to generate 3d
reconstructions then
conventional em approaches to understand
general ultrastructure of an object
finally we consider the computation
and data analysis resulting from
cryo-em imaging priority imaging
or conventional em energy
for this series of webinars we will
focus on the central pipeline
as illustrated in this red arrow and
these circles
for imaging of intact cells for light
microscopy
cryofluorescence light microscopy and
cryo-electron tomography
now we will highlight some of the
labeling strategies that have been used
for a range of biological targets
there are several key items to consider
when labeling an object of interest
first what are the options available to
the system
is the system a bit amenable to genetic
engineering
if not is immuno labeling an option
or could one develop a new technology
for label introduction i will now
highlight
these three labeling options used for
three independent
biological targets
increasingly cryo-em has become a
valuable tool
for structure-based drug design however
due to the more modest resolution gains
commonly achieved by cryo-electron
tomography
it has not been clear as to if cryo-et
structures could provide
feedback for drug discovery and design
applications
in this project we worked with our
collaborator to determine if
cryo-electron tomography could be
correlated with genetic
and immunological data to provide
validation
on an rsv vaccine candidate
for rsv early work on formalin
inactivated vaccines was not effective
due to negative impacts on children who
received the vaccine
therefore for many years vaccine
development was halted
until both molecular and structural
biology approaches matured
efforts focused on the development of
live attenuated vaccines
because one can balance the variables of
attenuation
with immunogenicity the other variable
that cryo-electron tomography imaging
could be used to investigate
is the physical nature of the rsv
vaccine candidate
dr moore and dr stobert engineered an
rsv vaccine candidate
candidate using codon deoptimization
as you can see here the map defines the
construct
and the alterations that were made
briefly on the native virus particles
three glycoproteins are present
sh g
and f most human immune responses
are to f the design goal for the
candidate was to modify
f for increased thermal stability
and maintenance of the pre-fusion
conformation
eliminate sh and decode on optimize g
to reduce both incorporated and secreted
g
we then collected cryo-et data
on a large number of virus particles to
assess the structure of the particles
and the glycoproteins studying the
surface
here as we slice through the 3d volumes
of the tomogram
we note the glycoprotein densities on
the surface of the particle
the maintenance of an intact viral
membrane
and the inclusion of the ribonuclear
protein complex or rnp
in the interior at this level of detail
we were confident that cryo-electron
tomography combined
with immunolabeling would be valuable
for assessing the physical character of
this vaccine candidate
for this work and other projects we
developed a native immuno-labeling
strategy
for surface-exposed complexes because it
was necessary for us to have a way to
label and identify the structures of
interest
and also retain the integrity of the
virus particles
and the macromolecular complexes
conventional immuno-labeling methods
incorporate steps of aldehyde fixation
vigorous washing and blocking we knew
from
conventional light microscopy and em
experiments
that a number of these processes damage
the ultrastructure
and find structure of virus particles
the native labeling approach was
performed under physiological growth
conditions
and in culture media the general steps
used preserve the virus
and cellular ultrastructure this method
could also be used for conventional
immunoem imaging for greater correlation
and validation of results if
fluoronantic gold conjugates or used
one can also do clem experiments
our results are shown in the figure
panel at the bottom
in a we see a cell extension with
assembling
and released virus particles
surrounding the periphery
b and c are cryo-em images
of two fields where several rsv
particles have immunogold
labeling on the s-glycoprotein
panel d is a slice through the 3d
tomogram
where black arrowheads denote gold
particles
that are associated with the f
glycoprotein
further quantification of cryo et
and conventional em of the immunolabeled
particles allowed us to determine the
ratios of pre
intermediate and post-fusion f present
on the vaccine candidate as compared to
wild-type virus particles
the results confirmed those of other
experiments that there was a greater
number of pre-fusion f
on the particles indicating the success
of the genetic approach used to produce
the candidate
our laboratory research also centers
around structural studies of bacteria
and their appendages namely the flagella
and the pili that supports cell motility
and interactions with abiotic
and biotic surfaces we use colobactor
crescentus
as a model system because of its
dimorphic life cycle
and the presence of polarly localized
flagella
and pili
that are present during the swimming and
swarmer phase of the life cycle
in this study we and our collaborators
sought to determine whether the pili
were able to both extend
and retract and to quantify the force of
attraction for one pillar
and multiple pillai
here in this study we were also
interested in labeling a periodic
surface exposed structure i.e the pilus
however conventional genetically encoded
tags could potentially alter the
structure of the pill and monomer
and its ability to self-assemble into
the pilus filament
in kind immuno-labeling approaches while
effective
could alter the function of the pillars
during extension
and perhaps retraction
therefore our collaborators
developed a method for introducing
cysteine residues
into the pill and monomer these residues
were positioned so that malaya mine dyes
could associate with
pillions along the length of the
pillow's filament
in time course phase contrast and
fluorescence microscopy imaging
still eye works were observed to extend
and retract from the cell poles as you
can see
where the blue arrow is present we
followed up on these experiments
with cryoclimate imaging to study the
structure of the cell
the cell pole and the pillar filament
during extension and retraction
in this figure panel we have a
cryofluorescence
microscopy image in a here we see
several collaborator cells that are auto
fluorescing in the green channel
with the pillars with the
and have the af
594 malayamai dye and the red channel
associated with the pillis filament
we collected a series of cryo-clem
images and transferred those for the
cryotem
for imaging panel b shows where we
identified the exact same cell in
a and in c
we have a slice through the 3d
reconstruction of that cell
with a pillow filament extended in that
particular slice
the rendered view in d notes the pili
in blue and the cell wall structures in
orange
yellow and red
this study was one of the first
instances where the leica
em cryo clem was used to study bacteria
and the structure functions of bacterial
appendages
our third example is of how labeling
strategies can be effectively used for
time course experiments
in this case our collaborators were
interested in determining the timing of
and structural changes that occurred
during the process of hiv attachment
fusion and entry
they engineered a pseudotype virus that
contained a yfp tag
on vpr and an m cherry tag
on the gag polyprotein in live cell
imaging experiments
when the virus particle is intact the
signal from the two labels
is co-localized
when the host when the particle fuses
with the host cell associated membranes
and the particle contents is released
the co-localized signal is no longer
present
multi-color labeling strategies are very
effective however in some cases the
events can be sparse
cells may be too thick for em imaging
and there can be challenges associated
with freezing
this is where imaging by fluorescence
microscopy and cryo fluorescence
microscopy can help to resolve these
challenges prior to imaging the samples
by cryo-em
the figure panel here walks us through
the cryo clem process panel a is an
overlaid image of the cryo clem
map onto the cryo-em low magnification
path
here we are able to pinpoint regions of
interest
on the em grid and in the images
and in the collection of navigator files
that contain the coordinate
information in panels b and c
we have a series of higher magnification
overlays that provide
greater information about the grid
square
the cell edge and the labeling of the
virus particles on that cell
this region was selected for
cryo-electron tomography data collection
and we were able to identify several
virus particles
in e f and g for further analysis
here i will play a movie about cryo
electron tomorrow
dataset this movie illustrates not only
the power
of cryoqlim for locating biological
targets of interest
on large surface areas of the grid and
the cells present on a grid
it also shows the value of whole cell
cryoet
for investigating the ultrastructure of
cells
and the structures of cell components as
we slice through the 3d volume
noted with red arrows are the virus
particles
and green boxes of mitochondria the
purple arrows
are polyribosomal complexes and in the
purple box
is a ribosome studded vesicle also
revealed in this data set
are long stretches of microtubules and
actin networks
their presence and stable structures are
indicative of our success in preparing
the samples for the
light microscopy and freezing process
for downstream cryoqlim
and cryoet imaging
during this next portion of the webinar
i'll provide you with some information
about equipment systems and workflow
development and designs for cryoglim
we all have really exciting biological
questions that would benefit from light
and electron microscopy imaging
however we may not know what resources
we need for addressing these questions
and whether we should house them in our
own laboratories
or use them as part of a shared resource
there are a lot of options available for
the equipment
and decisions regarding the systems to
purchase and use depend on many
experimental factors that are generally
determined
during the initial development of a
project and
those are refined over its course
for the ideal and highly automated
cryoklem workflow
one will need access to a live cell
imaging system
a plunge freezer cryo clem microscope
a cryofib sim for sample tuning and a
cryotem
in the next few slides i will show you
some of the results of studies
with more modest instrument setups
in this clem study to determine the
organization and structure of tether and
restricted hiv particles
that had budded from cells we had access
to
live cell imaging systems plunge
freezers and a side entry cryotem
this was an effective workflow and we
are able to correlate between the live
cell imaging
data and the cryo-em tomography data to
resolve the hiv particles
and the tethering protein
we were fortunate that we did not lose
our points of interest between the time
of imaging and plunge freezing
or during sample transfer steps pre and
post
plunge freezing
in a follow-up set of cryo-clean
experiments we replicated the previous
results
and improved correlation to multiple
targets by using the leica cryo clem
system
post sponge freezing
and prior to cryo tem imaging
we were able to rapidly overlay the
white microscopy
and em images and transfer the
coordinate positions between the
cryoklim
and the cryotem which set up our data
collection process
as with the previous experiments we did
have to take care during
multiple transfer steps to minimize
damage to the specimen vms handling
or sample warming that could cause
devitrification
we were limited in our investigations to
the periphery of cells
due to sample thickness considerations
when one has access to the full set of
equipment for cryo-em and cryo-clean
studies
limitations associated with time course
experiments or sample thickness
can be eliminated however we
still may experience some pitfalls
associated with sample damage due to
mishandling
de-vitrification or other items examples
of the entire workflow we'll present in
will be presented in a future webinar in
the series
so how do we practically do cryo class
we have developed a cryo-clem workflow
that includes standard operating
procedures in areas that may require
optimization
to improve the success rate of cryoklem
experiments
for the novice and experienced
practitioner
this workflow is conveniently color
coded to help the investigator work
through each step
and the associated steps of the process
in order to help individuals plan and
troubleshoot wholesale cryoklim
experiments
i will outline a few of the critical
steps within the workflow in the
subsequent slides
arguably one of the most critical items
for wholesale cryoglim success
is the substrate onto which the cells
adhere
there are many options for the
substrates
the most commonly used one is gold grids
because they are not toxic to cells
the gold grid is the base upon which an
additional support layer is applied
and this is typically in our instances a
carbon film
the film is necessary for cells to
adhere to and spread over the grid
surface
when we examine the overall architecture
of the grid
we have the options of using just
standard mesh these over here
center marked mesh or a finder grid
finder grids are extremely helpful
because they have fiduciary markers
present that aid in correlation
experiments
the style of the carbon film either
solid or co-created depends on user
preference
and data or collection requirements
when we transition to grid preparation
there are a number of considerations
briefly one should have a standard set
of tools
and equip land laboratory equipment to
minimize specimen contamination
and continuity of research we prefer
to use mass tech dishes
for the experiments because they have a
glass cover slip in the bottom that
allows for periodic light microscopy
imaging
without the introduction of grid
handling steps
that could damage the grid or the cells
that are cultured onto them
we may also add an additional layer of
carbon to the grid surface to improve
substrate stability
and increase what we term cell happiness
finally we may add in this stage
an extracellular matrix protein across
the grid surface
i.e on top of the carbon film to enhance
cell adhesion
and spreading finally
we also add fluorescent and electron
dense markers
to the sample to support correlation
experiments and image alignment
during the reconstruction process
in short we have had great success with
culturing a wide range of cell types
on em substrates for cryo-em and
cryo-clem experiments
these include bacterial cells mammalian
cells
both laboratory and strains as well as
primary cells
cells can be co-cultured together and
perturbed with various treatments such
as transfection and
infection as mentioned earlier there are
many types
there are many techniques that may be
used to label cells for a correlative
imaging pipeline
and we've used a multitude of these
during the initial stages of an
experiment
we will image the cells to assess growth
and their happiness level as well as
labeling efficiency
and cell thickness as we can see here in
this knee stack
if cells do not spread well or are
thicker than approximately 750
nanometers
we may consider the use of a sectioning
or milling
approach prior to cryo-em imaging to
thin the cells
sufficiently
once you've prepared your sample image
it by light microscopy
and vitrified it via plunge freezing or
high pressure freezing approach
it is time yay for cryofluorescence
microscopy imaging
there are many options available for use
the selection of the system depends on
the attributes of the particular system
as well as the biological target you're
interested in
ideally one would use a clem system that
is part of a seamless workflow
has minimal transfer steps between the
systems or methods
for handling that eliminate possible
sample damage
and the imaging and coordinate data is
rapidly correlated
with another instrument's software
for our work
we have had great success with the leica
em cryo clem system
for studies of bacteria human cells and
virus-infected cells
finally we will we consider the tem that
is available at your institution
and or through a consortium or a
national laboratory
there are two major models
side entry-style microscopes and all the
autoloader style microscopes
both are extremely valuable tools for
use in specimen screening
and data collection in many cases the
instruments can be set up for
semi-automated or automated data
collection routines
we have used both types for our cryo
clean clem studies
and cryo-electron tomography studies of
cells and the results
from each have enabled us to resolve the
biological question
that we were engaged in addressing
so as with all areas of structural
biology
we are looking at the future of clem
imaging
are there improvements to the methods
and technologies that will lead to
better and faster results yes absolutely
most critically we should have dedicated
patient and creative personnel for the
novice user
we can have well-developed standard
protocols for them to follow
we typically focus on in our lab
the improvement of substrates and cell
culturing methods
through micro patterning and
microfluidics
and we are also engaged in developing
improved automation routines
through software and hardware advances
that said
there are many other advances that can
be made including to labeling strategies
additional hardware advances and there
may be other needs
to include minimizing transfer steps
in the following slides i will highlight
the areas that we are interested in
in particular how to improve cell
culture and substrates
and software routine
now this is just a preview of the
subsequent webinar that will follow
um and so as you've noted throughout
this webinar we have a robust workflow
for cryo-clean studies of virus-infected
cells
this workflow relies on tools from leica
namely the emgp
and the em cryo clem system
with these tools in hand we are
developing improved routines for better
automation and correlation
between cryofluorescence microscopy
images
and cryon data
in this slide jay yang a postdoctoral
fellow in the lab
demonstrates an improved workflow for
correlation between
cryofluorescence microscopy and cryovm
data
the data is of an rsv-infected cell
where the native immunolabeled virus
particles fluoresce green
you can see here in particular in this
yellow box
in the cryo et reconstruction we resolve
the structure of the virus particle that
was identified in the cryofluorescence
microscopy map
of note the label used was fluoronate
gold
we're able to resolve the nanogold
particles associated
with the f glycoprotein on the surface
of the virus particle
a second really exciting area of
development in the lab
is micro patterning to support complex
cell culturing experiments
and approved automation for cryo club
the leading rationale for micro
patterning is that cells
in the body do not grow in 2d or in
isolation from one another
therefore technologies can be developed
to support the expansion
of native in-situ microenvironments on a
substrate
this will expand our capacity to
understand fundamental cell biology
and design experiments to tease out
architectural
mechanical physiological and other
structural and functional relationships
present between cells and tissues and
organ systems
in the lab we have a leica
dmi8 microscope with the alveol primo
micro
patterning system this is an extremely
user friendly system that allows us to
pattern substrates easily
for cell culture experiments the system
is also housed in the same room as the
cryo clean
and plunge freezing instruments this
makes
transitions between the three pieces of
equipment easy
and workflows easily accessible to users
in addition
experimental timelines are on the order
of 24 to 48 hours
moving from the micro patterning system
and basic light level imaging
through to clem of course this very much
depends
on the timing of how long it takes for
cells to
grow and spread on the em grids
in a sneak peek for one of the upcoming
webinars on micro patterning for cell
biology
i wanted to highlight a few
different patterns that brian generated
on the grid surface transferred to the
grid film
he then applied the ecm but then
supported the growth of hela cells
for subsequent light microscopy and
cryo-em imaging
and here you can see the two different
patterns brian applied to the grid
one is straight lines covering the grid
they're highlighted in the lighter color
and then the lower pattern
is one of a slightly deformed triangle
and in each case the gila cells as they
were cultured onto the grid
uniformly adhered and maintained the
coverage
over those micro patterned environments
and finally when we look at ng a cryo-em
image
we can resolve the cell body where it's
in the particular spatial arrangement
over the micro patterned region
so we're super excited about this
technology
and the advances to cell biology that it
will support
so many times we ask ourselves well
what's next
so how do i begin my project my
recommendations
are to contact vendors about the latest
technologies this is something i do
frequently
or ask a member of the cryo of a cryo-em
research facility
or cryo-em research lab for a
consultation
and discussions on how to move forward
with your project
many people are available to you in the
community and everybody is super
responsive and supportive of one another
and we're happy to answer
your questions and assist with your
experiments
i've also provided a few reference site
materials for
leica as well as alveol so you can
contact them directly
to find out more information about cryo
glem technologies and micro patterning
tools
at this time i'd like to acknowledge a
few members of the
the large team that supported these
research endeavors
both at uw-madison and emory university
initially i'd like to
thank the members of my group the alumni
who have moved on to do other things
they really set their foundation for the
lab's development
and infectious disease research the
members of the group had developed the
initial stages of cryoklem
where sherry josh rebecca
then long and hong currently in the lab
at uw
jay bryan and joe are the ones leading
the charge and developing clem
technologies and micro patterning
for our expanded studies in infectious
disease
and cellular dysfunction
for our biological targets we had a
really great group of collaborators
supporting our research efforts in hiv
rsv and call of actor research
finally i'd like to thank our vendors
from
leica and alveo in particular leica we'd
like to thank dr louise bertrand and
miss nancy rizzo
and from alveol dr aurelian dubois
and mr serge kadura
at this point i'd like to highlight our
upcoming webinars in the series
so we have four additional webinars the
first webinar will be held on thursday
july 2nd
and this is a webinar to show
how to improve grid preparations for
cryo climbs
including micro patterning technologies
this is a hands-on workflow webinar
where we will share videos
of how we prepare the grids and
different tips and tricks
for improving your capacity to do
correlative cryo vm
experiments
following the this webinar will have
three scientific results
uh webinars that discuss improvements
for automated
automation and correlative microscopy
workflows
call us at the imaging of host pathogen
interactions
and advancements for correlative imaging
of
cell to cell interactions
we'd like to thank you for joining us
today and your attention
and we are we'll now pause for questions
and thank you dr wright for that
informative presentation
and i want to welcome dr seibert and dr
yang
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
and if you have any questions you'd like
to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
so we have quite a few questions already
coming in
and i'm going to start with you dr
wright
my tech dishes do not have flat bottom
glass
compared to wilco is
that cannot affect visualization of
viruses
entering in the cells
that's an excellent question in our case
with some many of the collaborators
we're working with they've been using
matte tech dishes for some time for all
levels
of fluorescence microscopy work so it
was
we had a lot of confidence in that we
wouldn't have any problems associated
with being able to visualize
the virus entry or events of virus
assembly
in the samples so we haven't experienced
any difficulties with the matte tech
dishes alone or
with the samples being on matte tech
dishes
or em grids that are then
sitting in the matte tech dishes you can
also
contin adjust where your z plane is
to allow you to focus and follow the
events of interest
thank you for that question and thank
you
and dr seibert this next question is for
you is this
micro patterning technique compatible
with all tam grid
yes so we have used the micro patterning
on
carbon coated gold and nickel grids
as well as silicone grids we haven't had
any grids that
it wasn't successful on
thank you for that and dr yang viruses
are
very small below the wide field
resolution
less than 200 um
how could you be certain that the
localization of both
fluorophores is specific to the
structures observed
in cryo condition when fluorescent is
not visible in the cryo-em
very good question so generally people
do several things
to actually improve the correlation
accuracy as well as the signals they are
looking for under the cryoflung
so right now with the leica system you
can actually achieve theoretically
somewhere between like 200 to 600
nanometers
uh resolution and then that's way below
the 200
micron for that question and then the
next part is that
you also need to if you want to achieve
really high accuracies for the
correlation you can also use floor
sphere which is feeds
and those speeds are generally very
small and way much smaller than
the point spread functions the half the
full length and the
have maximum densities that values
so generally it fill right into the
range
and then you can actually image them if
you can get a really good correlation
accuracy you can generally image the
particles
a lot of groups have success in the
particles
with the diameter range from 50
nanometers
to 100 nanometers
thank you and dr wright which step
tends to have the most user errors
again an excellent question typically we
see the most challenges during specimen
handling and transfer steps
this is because we are typically using
gold grids which are extremely fragile
and inexperienced users may
inadvertently damage the grid while
they're handling the
grid with tweezers and and other
you know manipulators so this is one
reason why many research groups and
vendors are developing workflows that
minimize the steps where individual
grids
i.e and isolation are handled and
they're doing this by preloading the
grid into some sort of stabilizing unit
or or even more so within a chuck
type system that then can be transferred
between one microscope to the next
thank you for the question
thank you very much and actually dr
right i'll give you another one what
cell thickness is appropriate for the
cells on the grid
sure this is a question we get uh
frequently
um so we have had a great success for
culturing cells of all thicknesses on em
grids and i should say we are either
culturing cells
or we're laying down cells on the grids
that are separate from one another so we
are not
at this point in time growing a
confluent monolayer
we still want the cells to have
separation between one another so that
we also have exposed areas of the grid
showing
especially if we're doing correlative
microscopy so we can have those points
of correlation
in addition when we are some of our
experiments
we're looking at cell peripheries so we
want to have those
regions exposed so generally
mammalian or human cells are on the
order of 2 to 15 microns at their
maximum z dimension
these are cells we're culturing on grids
you know and this would be around the
nucleus
the points to consider here are will you
have complete vitrification of the cells
on the grid if you're using plunge
freezing
and when this is a concern one may want
to use a cryoprotectant in the media
prior to freezing
or if the region of interest for your
project is really in the thickest
portion of the cell
you may want to consider suctioning a
cryo-sectioning or a cryo-milling
technique
prior to the cryo-tem imaging or
if your sample is quite thick where you
would not get
complete vitrification using plunge
freezing method
you may want to consider high pressure
freezing
freeze substitution and more
conventional tem imaging
thank you so much dr wright and this
next question is for you dr yang and
it's a two-part question
how many fluorophores can we image with
the cyroclem and how long does it take
to acquire
a tile scan of the whole grid
great question so right now the floral
force we
applied we applied like a two
types of the chloroforms depends on our
experiments we apply
either 100 nanometers or 500 nanometers
uh 100 nanometers within or like 200
nanometers
if we don't want to use a 500 nanometers
uh 100 nanometers we use it for
the localization accuracy estimation and
correlation
and the 5 and 200 nanometers will also
use that to
help us do the correlation and for how
long it takes to get a
uh prior clean this process uh the
longest time take is actually for the
scanning of the tile
or the entire grid and then generally it
takes 40 minutes 30 to 40 minutes
it also depends on the z stacks
you choose to collect on each tile and
then we generally for cells we use 15
micron
and then also depends on the uh the
steps
you use we use the nyquist which is 350
nanometers so you can actually get a
better image for
later deconvolution processing
thank you for that and dr cyber what
kind of
shape geometry can be patterned on the
grid
so a great question any shape or pattern
that you can think of
can really be used during the micro
patterning the minimum
size is going to be determined by the
resolution of your
particular device the the primo system
has a resolution of less than two
microns when you're using a 20x
objective and
we have routinely done patterns with
features as small as 5 microns
one thing you want to think about though
is you probably want your cells
on the carbon support in between the
grid bars
so you will want to design a pattern
that fits within those
single grid squares which are around 90
microns
and thank you and dr yang i'm going to
ask you a question because before i do i
want to thank our audience
because these are just great questions
and we have so many coming in
thank you so much dr ying what is the
time requirement for learning to be
proficient at each stage
of this workflow
great question i think it's really
depends on
the comfort levels of the users
generally i think right now with the
clean system leica system is it's much
easier because the
software layout is very clear i think
the majority of the time
a user have been spending on would be
the sample preparation
as well as a loading process that may
take some
practice and then it's generally take uh
probably ten like five to ten rounds to
get very comfortable
and thank you dr wright this next
question is for you
um first the audience member says hi
this is joanne from
clint nano medicine and how to cut the
cyril block
into slides for em without typical em
fixation and thank you for a
presentation she says
sure joanne that's an excellent question
and so it really depends
on your particular sample that you're
imaging so in our case
we're doing cells that are cultured and
less than a monolayer
and so one of the techniques that has
become prominent today and remember
these are cryofix specimens
people are using cryofib sim so that's a
under cryo condition so better than
minus
150 degrees celsius you're inserting
that into a scanning electron microscope
that has a secondary beam that's the
focused ion beam
and so you can use that to mill down
your specimen
and so there's three major techniques
that can be used that i highlighted on
on one of the slides you can either
produce a lamella
you can do uh just sectioning off the
top and continue imaging
or you can cut out what's termed a list
out
and then transfer that to your grid
and then image just that lift out
portion and so there's a recent paper
by another group in the field and we're
happy to share
uh references to the literature uh that
has shown
using this technique uh on c elegans
one can also you do cryoultramicrotomy
to section material and senate for
cryo-em work if you needed to do
fixation because that was one of your
critical points you have the prospect of
doing
fixation or cryopreservation and then
subsequent free substitution
and embedding if your sample is way too
thick to consider doing any cryo milling
or sectioning approach
thank you again for your question
thank you and this next question is for
you dr seibert
um this is can this technique
be used to track gpcr
internalization
yeah uh i don't have that much
experience
with the gpcr internalization myself
but if it's something that you can
track with fluorescence and
electron microscopy then this technique
should be
applicable to that as well
thank you so much this next question
actually is another question for you dr
seibert and we have time for a couple
more questions
the audience member says i read an
article
on cryo e m structure of the 2019 encode
spike in the profusion confirmation of
rap um at l it's interesting that you've
studied the hiv
chemokine receptors and rsv viruses
how feasible is the application of the
microscopy
in the study of the pathogenesis of
stars cove to
virus
yeah that's a great question and
actually it's
very applicable to the study of the sars
kovi
to virus similar to the other studies
that he mentioned
i think many groups are already using
cryo-em
to study the sars kobe 2 and there's
already several
cryo-em structures that have published
and this is an exciting use of this
technique
to learn more about that virus
thank you for that our next question is
for you
dr wang can the techniques be used
to track gpcr internalization
uh um
the gpcr internalization
yeah i'm not very familiarized with the
size of that
complex but i think that is probably
really small
i guess right now the most success
people get
is actually from the 50 to 100
nanometers
they can use to track it i think it's
doable
under the fluorescent conditioning it's
going to be probably challenging
to localize them very precisely just
due to the size of the complex
thank you so much this next question is
for you
dr cyber i'm trying to find it i just
had it um
actually let me just ask this next
question
um and i'll open it up for whichever one
of you would like to answer it
do you require binoculars on the plunge
freezers for freezing adherent cells or
suspension of cells
on grids using leica gp or
other plunge freezers and or do you
or excuse me or do other plunge freezers
work too
so this is liz i'm happy to take that
question
so on our leica emgp we do have the
binocular feature uh incorporated into
it
and so this is really useful when we're
training new users
on how to use the the unit so that they
can
see how their grid is being manipulated
and how the filter paper is coming in
and blotting it and so they can really
dial in the conditions that we're
interested in for for manipulating the
sample we don't always use binoculars
for
visualizing the grids during the process
either on the emgp
or other systems that we have in the lab
it's really
you know training new people starting
with a new sample
and then once you have everything dialed
in then you can move on to not
necessarily checking it every time
thank you very much and dr cyber this is
our last question
for today regarding the micro patterning
process
are there some limitations with the
patterns
yeah thanks that's a another great
question
um not really so again any
any shape or pattern that you can make
in a illustrator or a computer software
program
can then be projected onto the grid
and with the primo system it can even do
different levels of patterning so
you can have areas of your pattern with
more
ecm adhered than other areas of your
pattern
so it's really powerful flexible
technique and again i'd say the only
limitation
is going to be the the minimum
resolution which is
around 2 microns
thank you so much dr cyber and i want to
thank all three of you dr wright dr
seibert dr yang thank you very much for
your presentation today
do you have any final comments for our
audience before we close
hi sarah thank you for asking that well
i think our final comment would be just
reach out to your vendors your local em
experts and and others in the community
and ask questions like you've asked us
today we're sorry we couldn't address
all of them
but we will happily address them offline
and we will
it's just you have to try there's no
limit to the technologies and being able
to use
em cryo-em and light microscopy to
resolve a variety of different
biological questions
oh and stay tuned for our next webinar
in the series
which is really a virtual hands-on
webinar
where we will show you some of the steps
of how we actually
manipulate cells on the grids and use
micro patterning
and walk you through the steps of the
process so that
hopefully we're providing you with some
confidence that you can go out and
test drive these experimental techniques
on your system of interest
we really appreciate your time today
and we appreciate your time thank you
again dr wright dr seibert dr yang for
your today
and for your contributions to cell
biology and i also like to thank
lab roots and our sponsors leica
microsystems and naviol for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i want to remind the
audience thank you for joining us today
and for interesting questions and
questions we didn't have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via contact information
be provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share this email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time take care
be safe bye